Hindu Sikh Christian Brothers we are one
now and forever they chant this is a day
of peaceful but noisy protest against
India's citizenship law in Ludhiana and
across the state of Punjab outside the
main mosque the minority Muslim
community and making their voices heard
and the majority Sikh community are
joining them Nevada if they target the
largest minority after the Hindus in
this country and who will they go for
next from all religions it will be the
poor that are worst affected like many
in this community they're unhappy with
the government's move to alienate their
Muslim brothers you're going to oppose
this black law and stand by our brothers
and maintain our strong bonds the
strength of feeling is growing in the
past few days thousands have taken to
the streets to show solidarity with the
Muslims and oppose the new citizenship
law we are not rendered anybody that
wasn't the position of the leading Sikh
opposition party in Punjab the Shiromani
Akali Dal party they are allies of Prime
Minister Narendra Modi's government and
supported the change if we would have
been denying the right to one lakh six
who were asking for the citizenship so
then after deliberations we decided not
to oppose it and to rather vote for it
so that is the reason that we voted for
it but now facing faced criticism from
the Sikh faith Smith senior figurehead
priests gyani her Preet Singh who was
Muslims to be included in the
citizenship law the Akali Dal party
chief has done a complete u-turn and
this could lead to a split with Modi's
BJP party in New Delhi nearly two
percent of Punjab's population is Muslim
that often thought of as an important
voting bloc seen a swing voters but a
major move by a large Sikh party like
the SA D could well influence those
voters across the board
towards the SATs opponents the Congress
party and its allies they currently
control the state of Punjab in the last
general election secular candidates
consolidated their victories across
Punjab
and much of the credit was given to the
Muslim vote while any future election is
a long way off
changing opinion is all the senior
Muslim priests at this mosque can do for
now we are happy today that I see Hindu
Christian and Dalit brothers protested
with us we all realized this isn't just
one community's issue it's the whole
nation and we are all affected by
discrimination it's an opinion held by
many as rallies continue across India's
major cities Sahil raman al jazeera
Ludhiana Punjab